[Musica]
[Applauso]
un piano b per i consumatori
vediamo generalmente il consumatore
quando acquista qualcosa non pensa ad un
piano b crede che tutto vada per il
meglio ed in effetti generalmente le
cose vanno bene al più curiosamente sono
le aziende apre confezionare un piano b
per il consumatore
soddisfatti o rimborsati
recita la pubblicità ci avete mai
pensato e poi c'è quello spot che mi ha
sempre fatto un po impressione quando
lanciano l'ultima autovettura sul
mercato ma nessuna paura fra tre anni
sei libero di restituirla una specie di
piano b con una scadenza predeterminata
insomma è chiaro se compriamo un
prodotto un servizio questo soddisfa le
nostre aspettative
tutto finisce lì e non c'è bisogno di
costruire percorsi alternativi ma anche
se qualcosa non va per il verso giusto
il consumatore non è che sia molto
incline a protestare a reclamare a farsi
sentire al più mastica amaro cosa
facciamo borbottato qualcosa
pubblichiamo qualche parola feroce sui
social ma le cose finiscono lì
nessun piano b ma è un peccato e davvero
un peccato rinunciare a farci sentire
perché la storia è piena piena zeppa di
piani b sviluppati come reazione ad un
evento negativo comincia raccontando
bene uno anni 90 c'è una catena di
videoteche molto ampia 8 mila negozi nel
mondo si chiama blockbuster che fa soldi
letteralmente a palate con il noleggio
dei film in videocassetta ma attenzione
fa soldi anche in un'altra maniera
richiedendo ai consumatori delle penali
delle penali esorbitanti se qualcuno
riporta il film noleggiato con qualche
giorno di ritardo
in questa storia incappa un certo reed
hastings riconsegna apollo 13 la
videocassetta del film apollo 13 con
qualche giorno di ritardo e lì vengono
richiesti 40 dollari di penale il nostro
consumatore e batte i pugni sul tavolo
prova a gridare le sue giustificazioni
ma non ne viene a capo
40 dollari sull'unghia e tanti saluti
ma tanti saluti e nel vero senso della
parola perché quel consumatore e promise
a se stesso di non rimettere mai più
piede dentro un negozio di blockbuster e
non solo
provo a ragionare su cosa ai consumatori
davvero volessero quanti altri
consumatori nella sua stessa situazione
non si erano fatti sentire non avevano
reclamato
escogitò un nuovo modello di business
non più videocassette ma dvd non più il
rischio di penali per i consumatori ma
un abbonamento la cosa più comoda del
mondo e poi quando la tecnologia di idee
la possibilità di vedere i film in
streaming beh il gioco era fatto
era nata netflix oggi 150 milioni di
clienti in oltre 200 paesi
un fatturato da 20 miliardi di dollari
la ritardata consegna di apollo 13
secondo molti è una leggenda
mentre netflix come noi tutti sappiamo
ha fatto la storia
insomma potrei farne molti altri esempi
ma il concetto credo sia chiaro cos'è il
piano b per i consumatori è la capacità
di adattarsi ad una situazione nuova di
individuare gli errori commessi e
ripartire dalle scelte azzeccate detto
così sembra facile ma per farlo è
necessario un ingrediente essenziale e
cioè il dialogo è necessario che i
consumatori e imprese si parlino tra
loro e non sempre accade qualche giorno
fa mi ritrovo a gironzolare in uno di
quegli show room pieni di mobili di
arredamento e soprattutto tanti tanti
divani da un certo punto la mia
attenzione viene attratta dal cartello
che trovo su uno di questi divani
vietato sedersi come vietano se diversi
mi guardo intorno e scopro che su quasi
tutti i sofà in esposizione c'era lo
stesso cartello vietato sedersi
l'interruzione di un dialogo che ci sta
a fare quel divano all'interno di uno
showroom se il consumatore non può
nemmeno provarlo
mi guardo intorno
su quello scaffale altro cartello non
toccare e vicino ad una cucina un po più
in là vietato aprire
piante insomma sono solo qualche solo
qualche esempio ma molti altri stanno
venendo in mente anche a voi di quel
dialogo muto sordo
che avviene ad esempio all'interno dei
dei negozi è mai capitato di chiedere
qualcosa un'informazione al commesso e
sentirvi rispondere così in modo un po
distratto e non so io quando chiedo il
pacco regalo alla cassa mi guardano come
se fossi un marziano come se avessi
fatto una richiesta davvero fuori dal
mondo ora non voglio generalizzare ma
anche quando giriamo per le strade della
nostra città quante volte troviamo un
cartello vicino ai tavolini di un bar
all'aperto
riservato al servizio al tavolo insomma
siamo alle solite ancora una volta
vietato sedersi e quanto spesso sentiamo
parlare di employer branding quella
detto alle vendite che dovrebbe gli
stesso diventare ambasciatore del
prodotto dovrebbe parlare con il
consumatore che è andato a trovarlo
all'interno del centro commerciale
niente di tutto ciò è vicino alla cassa
ancora un altro cartello la merce non si
cambia il l'ha detto non alza nemmeno
una testa indica quelle tavole della
legge iscritte da qualche parte sulla
sua testa seacrest non si può discutere
come avrete capito sono ossessionato dai
cartelli la buona notizia è che lo
faccio per lavoro e se raccontato fin
qui di questi cartelli e per spiegarvi
che sono soltanto una di quelle
situazioni nelle quali si spegne il
dialogo la relazione tra imprese e
consumatori
la direzione non risponde di questo o di
quello non si fanno sconti
insomma il cartello inoppugnabile non è
possibile per il consumatore reagire ma
come ci hanno raccontato e soprattutto
in facoltà come queste ve lo raccontano
tutti i giorni che i mercati sono
conversazioni sono esattamente questo
sono dialoghi interlocuzioni poi però il
venditore sembra essere lì per onor di
firma e mi viene in mente un'altra
storia che mi riguarda quando mi
sottopongo in un modulo
io mi arrabbio da morire davvero di
vento tutto rosso se mi viene chiesta
una firmetta so se è capitato anche a
voi una firmetta a per perché questo
diminutivo questo vezzeggiativo il senso
e di ridurre l'importanza del dialogo
ancora una volta una firmetta non ti
preoccupare poi non so se avete notato
spesso ci mettono una croce proprio
vicino a dove dobbiamo firmare il
venditore più accorto mette anche il suo
dito firma qui perché perché
l'attenzione del consumatore deve essere
limitata a quel centimetro quadrato
zitto basta firma niente di più
re indosso per un attimo i panni
dell'avvocato il contratto sarebbe in
linea teorica l'incontro delle volontà
delle parti e firmando manifesto la mia
volontà se qualcuno vuole annichilire
questo dialogo in qualche modo tradisce
anche i miei diritti come accade con
quei contratti con i caratteri scritti
piccoli piccoli piccoli davvero
illeggibili o viceversa coi contatti
dove ci sono scritte tantissime parole
cosa cosa fate come reagiamo non ne
voglio nemmeno entrare
non voglio nemmeno guardarlo quel
contratto altrimenti diventa un lavoro
ora so che qualcuno di voi sta pensando
forse che tutti questi esempi hanno a
che fare con il commercio tradizionale
con la cosiddetta old economy che
proprio per questo è a buon diritto sta
per essere spazzata via dal digitale
bene sappiate che queste storie di
mancata conversazione avvengono anche
online
sì che il digitale avrebbe i superpoteri
per rafforzare la relazione con il
consumatore le pure talvolta è un luogo
anche quello anche i siti di informative
illeggibili sono quelle nuance di colore
praticamente impercettibili casar le
prepagate cioè sto pensando qualcosa
contro la mia volontà banner che
appaiono all'improvviso ma non per darci
informazioni permetterci fretta al t3
consumatori stanno guardando quella
stessa stanza oddio devo correre devo
sbrigarmi il tutto per non discutere beh
questo è quello che fanno alcune aziende
non voglio naturalmente
generalizzare d'altra parte c'è però un
consumatore devo onestamente ammetterlo
che anche lì non è abbia poi tutta
questa voglia di chiacchierare
lo abbiamo detto davanti a un
disservizio di solito tiriamo via
insomma soprattutto se si tratta di
piccoli importi ma come dico sempre quel
consumatore che lascia perdere non
soltanto perde egli stesso ma
contribuisce ad una sconfitta più
complessiva è quella del mercato e la
storia che vi ho raccontato di
blockbuster se avesse avuto dei
consumatori che avessero spiegato cosa
non andava bene in quel servizio e
potrei citare nokia che forse non si è
accorta per tempo che i consumatori non
erano più interessati ai tasti fisici
sul sul telefonino forse dato il momento
di chiedersi perché imprese e
consumatori faticano a parlarsi anche se
spesso sentiamo dire che siamo
nell'epoca dell'ascolto del dialogo
ebbene ho un colpevole credo sia questo
paradigma del tutto e subito
ci ha reso impazienti possiamo ordinare
un prodotto e forse lo facciamo online
lo avremo a casa la sera stessa possiamo
decidere di mangiare un cibo esotico
ordiniamo una cena l'avremo
immediatamente a casa nostra
ecco io credo che sia proprio il
paradigma del tutto e subito ad aver
spento ogni slancio verso il piano b
in tutta questa città finiscono anche i
problemi dei consumatori siamo indotti
proprio perché è tutto così veloce a
tendere a passare subito avanti ho in
testa e l'immagine della slot machine
non so se ci pensate se l'allineamento
dei segni non ci soddisfa corriamo sulla
leva tiriamo giù per scatenare un'altra
visione ragazzi quello che accade sui
feed dei nostri social media con il dito
scorriamo scorriamo voracemente in
attesa di qualcosa che ci piaccia è come
trovare la voglia di lamentarsi meglio
tagliare i ponti dall'altra parte le
aziende ugualmente il tutto e subito ha
fatto credere ad alcune di loro che
fosse sufficiente aprire una pagina sui
social per autodichiararsi
data driven guidata dai dati guidata
dalle persone o fronte al futuro e
prendere per ciò solo di essersi
garantiti un posto nel futuro è vero il
digitale ci offre strumenti straordinari
per ascoltare i consumatori pensiamo ai
botta l'intelligenza artificiale alla
realtà aumentata ma molto più importante
e leggere gli small dei dai dati
minuscoli quelli che ci cita spesso
martin lindstrom i reclami inespressi le
insoddisfazioni sopite sapete perché
patagonia ha smesso di invitare i
consumatori a rottamare il proprio
giubbotto e invitandolo invece a a
ripararlo
proprio perché era in ascolto di questa
sensibilità molto sottile della sua
clientela del suo pubblico negli stati
uniti in una catena di abbigliamento che
si chiama nordstrom è nota per avere il
servizio cliente migliori del mondo
sapete cosa succede dentro nordstrom gli
addetti di fanno una confezione regalo
ma la cosa buffa è che vi impacchettano
anche il prodotto che il consumatore ha
comprato in un altro grande magazzino
persino se lo avete comprato da mesi il
suo concorrente
beh gli addetti di nostro vi fanno il
pacchetto regalo
e ricordate la storia del vietato
sedersi se non consumate starbucks vi fa
entrare anche se non consumate
all'interno del negozio perché perché
vuole vedere quel consumatore da vicino
vuole vederlo mentre agisce mentre
acquista un consumatore in carne ed ossa
non in un focus group
ci sono molte storie di aziende
predisposte al miglioramento continuo
quello che viene chiamato continuous
improvement sono costantemente
sintonizzate si chiama proprio find
tuning ci da l'idea di quella rotellina
che era sulla radio per cercare la
frequenza giusta ma per vedere il
consumatore in carne ed ossa bisogna
accoglierlo nel proprio negozio vi cito
altre due case gli apple store dove il
genius è lì per parlare con il
consumatore one to one infatti spesso
bisogna prendere un appuntamento
risponderà alle nostre esigenze di
consumatore ma farà molto di più
raccoglierà raccoglierà le nostre
insoddisfazioni per far sì che apple
possa migliorare i suoi prodotti è
ancora un altro un'altra storia leggo
leggo i negozi di lego sono famosi per
avere più spazio dove si può giocare
rispetto a quello dove si vende perché
evidentemente lega vuol vedere i suoi
piccoli clienti alla presa con i suoi
giocattoli e guardate questa non è
retorica del dialogo retorica pro
consumerista queste business sono dati
che ci raccontano che c'è un 6 per cento
del fatturato in pericolo in questa
forbice tra i desideri dei consumatori e
la visione di certe aziende ma che vi
presento il protagonista di questo talk
che sia vero ascolto che sia io lo
chiamo ascolto aumentato aumentato
perché è arricchito da almeno tre
vitamine chiamiamole così sono l'onestà
la proattività l'etica dei dati
cos'è l'onestà bisogna essere coerenti
con il proprio percorso bisogna essere
veritieri io non so voi ma se fossi un
millennio al nome ne farei nulla di una
carta di credito in legno sì è vero
sostituisce quella di plastica ma da
millenni la vorrei del tutto
smaterializzata proattività proattività
vuol dire essere empaticamente in
sintonia con il consumatore e anche
proattivi care aziende non lasciate
passare un giorno senza provocare voi
stesse un reclamo una segnalazione il
racconto di una insoddisfazione e poi
etica l'etica dei dati da consumerista
sono un po preoccupato di tutto questo
ascolto perché il carburante di questo
ascolto sono i nostri dati a volte un
uso eccessivo dei nostri dati e anche
qui c'è qualche storia da raccontare
sapete che spotify ha appena brevettato
un sistema per cui dall'ascolto del
nostro tenore di voce capisce qual è il
mio mood e mi propone una playlist in
linea con il mio umore forse qualcuno si
sta ci sta un po preoccupando ma è
soltanto una storia gli smart speakers
io sostengo che sia ingannevole anche il
nome perché più che speakers cioè
parlanti in realtà sono lì per ascoltare
quanti dati raccolgono e chiudere con la
stessa netflix con la quale son partito
sapete che se siete indecisi nello
scegliere un film o un altro presso
tardi avremo un tasto una funzione
guarda qualcosa
e netflix sceglierà per voi per noi ma
lo farà ancora una volta sulla base dei
nostri dati queste sono storie di
straordinario intuito di fronte ai quali
alle quali io mi tolgo il cappello ma è
cosa diversa l'ascolto aumentato e o un
ultima storia per voi
l'altro giorno mi scrive un consumatore
e lamentandosi di aver ricevuto la
consegna di un prodotto comprato su
amazon
nel pomeriggio di domenica ha
incuriosito gli rispondo cosa c'era che
non andava
pensavo si fosse irritato per la per
l'interruzione del riposo festivo beh no
quel consumatore si lamentava del fatto
che la piattaforma non prevedesse ancora
la possibilità di escludere la consegna
domenicale a beneficio di un lavoratore
che lui come consumatore non voleva far
lavorare di domenica e non sapete quanti
consumatori pagherebbero di piu la
consegna di un prodotto acquistato
online per averla green per averla verde
sostenibile ecco cari aziende se non
siete pronte ad ascoltare questi bisogni
sussurrati o peggio ancora se li
ritenete futili non siete pronte
all'ascolto aumentato le associazioni
dei consumatori in questo possono
esservi di aiuto almeno le più ispirate
tra questo possono collaborare a co
creare un nuovo percorso di crescita che
è ispirato all'ascolto aumentato possa
dare soddisfazione a una nuova condivisa
idea di sostenibilità
alla fine significa stare al passo con i
tempi significa
rispondere a quel che vuole la domanda a
quel che realmente
vuole la domanda come dovrebbe essere
dalla notte dei tempi
grazie per l'attenzione anzi per
l'ascolto aumentato
[Applauso]
[Musica]